and now it's time for tonight's hashtag
war
since we're here tonight with the
brilliant folks from drunk history who
get drunk and teach history we felt that
we should take a moment to remember the
towering figures who got drunk and made
history for example we all know the
Winston Churchill beat the out of
the Nazis but did you know is because
the Nazis bumped into him at a bar and
set a cigar made him look gay look at
that so comedians in honor of the
contribution of drunks in our past
tonight's hashtag is drunker history
examples might be Long Island iced tea
party or Madam hangover cure II I want
to put 60 seconds on the clock and begin
hey tweet a picture of your d-day yes
boys turn Abraham drinkin yes Derek
Waltons wine 11 always forget points
taking jello shots off a grassy knoll
all right points hero boozing B Anthony
yes points
Colton judge mojito in the OJ trial all
right boys very good Derek waters
Harriette sleeping in my tub man yeah